final hours of the election campaign and
now upon us party leaders has spent the
day dashing around the country to reach
as many voters as possible before the
polls open tomorrow morning from London
to the Midlands the Prime Minister has
called for a vote for the Conservatives
and called it a vote for stability
insisting only she can get a good break
sit deal if we lose just six seats the
government loses its majority and that
would mean that coalition of chaos with
labour the Lib Dems and the SNP it will
mean Jeremy Corbyn in number 10 John
MacDonald at the Treasury and what a
combination that would be we know they
would wreck our economy and what we also
know with Labour is that its ordinary
working people who always pay the price
Jeremy Corbyn however has been framing
the election as a choice between hope
and fear starting in Glasgow and ending
the day in Islington the Labour leader
says voters must decide on the type of
world they want to live in I ask all of
you in the few hours that remain in a
few hours that I think that support in
the few hours that remain until the
polls open tomorrow morning think very
hard talk to your friends talk to
neighbors talk to everyone in the
community of the choice before us
tomorrow to me it's a choice of the kind
of world kind of country we want to live
in it's a choice of this or cuts closure
and privatisation it's a choice quite
simply of hope or fear well I'm joined
now by the conservative former minister
for trade Lord Maude who's now senior
advisor of the law firm Covington so
this has been a terrible conservative
campaign by common consensus for the
Conservatives well what could they have
done differently well I mean when you
start with a 20-point lead and the polls
the general rule is don't do anything
that is you've only got downside so be
very careful I think Roy Jenkins before
the 1997 elections had all Tony Blair
had to do was carry this priceless Ming
vars across the slippery floor without
dropping it and I don't think Theresa
May has dropped
I think it hasn't had its hiccups most
campaigns I've been involved with do
have hiccups I was candidate in 19 1987
is the way awareness yeah where we had
quite a difficult campaign and and yet
we ended up with a majority of over a
hundred and so what people remember
afterwards is not the campaign they
remember the result and I would be
optimistic that the Conservatives will
get a decent majority tomorrow and I
think it's really important that they
should because you know this breaks it
negotiation is a huge thing for the
country and for our partners in Europe
and you know if there is any sense that
in our counterparts in the those
negotiating from the EU side that
Britain that the Prime Minister might be
pushed off course that there might be a
sense that in if they're just tough
enough they might have another go
another referendum and reverse it then
all the incentives are for them to be
very hard-nosed and make no concessions
whatsoever and yet the right result both
for Britain and for the rest of the EU
is to have a sensible pragmatic approach
that maximizes the trading ease removes
friction makes it a continues for it to
be a very open and interlinked economy
but for that to be the outcome tourism a
needs to be able to go in with a strong
mandate and a big majority behind her I
mentioned brexit there the the OECD has
this afternoon warned on the UK's
economic prospects in the event of a
hard brexit I mean what sort of outcome
do you think she's really genuinely
capable of obtaining well we'll have to
see it's not entirely in her gift that
takes to to negotiate I think she's
absolutely right to have said that in a
very one-sided bad deal for Britain
would be worse than no deal at all and I
hope there's work going on in the
government at the moment about preparing
it for that not an outcome anyone wants
but a one that we have to be prepared
for that there is no deal and you know
make the best of it because I always my
view is I did took no part in the
referendum
campaign I thought both sides were
talking very exaggerated making very
exaggerated claims that again and and I
thought if that's a vote to leave there
is some short-term downside natural
terms not over yet but there's longer
term upside opportunity but that depends
on Britain being a fantastic place to do
business you know at our best in the
last few decades we've been absolutely
the go-to destination for people around
the world and companies to put their
ideas to work their money their energy
and their businesses and they decide to
do that and double down on that but
isn't this the problem though but resume
has been procedure in this election
campaign as being anti-business things
like a cap on energy prices for example
I mean how does she rectify that I mean
do you think she's as anti business as
people are saying no I don't I
absolutely don't but I do recognize that
there is that perception and it's a
perception that in the aftermath of the
election needs to be corrected you know
this Conservative government that I hope
it will be needs to send a really
unequivocal signal that investment is
welcome here that the government will
over the years ahead do everything it
can through the right tax regime the
right regulatory regime the right
infrastructure the right training all of
those things to be as supportive of
business as it can be and that's the way
you maximize the upside opportunity that
there is for Britain a genuinely global
Britain outward-looking Britain in the
post brexit world and briefly George
Osborne's Evening Standard today his
editorial says the manifesto had little
of substance apart from a series of anti
business measures well no I don't think
that's fair I mean they did it had a
number of things in it probably rather
more than was prudent but you know I
mean this has to be a government that is
unequivocally pro-business in favor of
lower taxes you want this to be a place
where people and businesses don't mind
paying tax because they feel it's fair
and proportionate all right